for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
but Darkness has found us again prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
hello everyone Welcome to our big ticket
interview for Transformers at rise of
the Beast I am parin amrov and I have
the pleasure of talking with the cast of
the film Anthony Ramos Dominique
Fishback Toby wigwei and Liza koshy
congratulations I'm so happy to be
sitting with you all right now I got big
group question to kind of give everyone
out there a little bit of the lay of the
land here for each of you can you give
me your character's greatest strength
going into this war but then I also want
their greatest weakness the thing that
can do them in on this Mission uh his
greatest strength is uh I think his
courage to to go to battle
um I think his greatest weakness was his
feeling of uh not not not feeling good
enough you know I think it's his whole
life he's felt that way so I think he
he's over we watch him overcome that I
think Elena's greatest strength is her
mind and a lot of times her mind takes
her own adventures and so she can have
the perception of being brave but then
when she's called into battleship to
come in her weaknesses that she doesn't
quite know if she can do it yet I would
say reek's greatest strength is his
heart and how he sees things and his uh
people that they don't necessarily see
in themselves and he wants to bring them
to uh just a different space
and the weakness is he might not be able
to just fully go all the way through
with every single mission
foreign
yeah I would say RC's greatest strength
is her armor she's built for battle uh
but she's also disciplined like she gets
everybody together she reels in she's
like what's the plan let's execute yeah
he's on time on task on a mission
I don't know yeah
that was the right answer I feel like
you might be the only one who can uh say
that with confidence right now humans
are fallible and that is fine
um Anthony for you so he clearly has a
close relationship with Mirage why do
you think Mirage is lucky that he's the
human that he encountered something
about him that makes him quick to
believe but also very willing to to jump
in and help them they balance each other
right like Mirage doesn't take anything
seriously and I think no one takes
himself way too seriously I think they
they bring out this courage in one
another and they bring out these sides
in one another that um that they
wouldn't necessarily have without each
other you know and I think we see that
they work better as a team uh than when
they're by themselves why is it for you
so RC we have seen we have heard her
before what is it like finding the
balance between you know honoring the
version of the character that many out
there already know and love but making
this version uniquely your own as well
yeah I mean I got to tap into a version
of myself I hope I become now from
playing her she is so like Furman in her
power and she is computer now don't you
it's a lower register that I drop into
in order to be there and Stephen Stephen
Campbell Jr just made it so easy for me
you know he gets real passionate about
the character he bends his knees in a
deep squat he's like okay then you're
gonna jump over there
yeah he's a brilliant director so you
know he was so collaborative with me too
to help me find this character and find
my version of her too
um so we did a little dancey dance and
then we found her and I'm excited to see
what y'all think because you brought up
Steven I want to sing his Praises
because a big part of the reason I was
really excited about this movie was when
I heard he signed on of all people so
can you maybe tell me something about
him as a director and leader on this set
that you know makes you think man
Transformers fans are really lucky
because there's no person out there
other than him that could have brought
this to screen this way
you said it I mean to be honest he's you
know working with him you know I learned
so much not only as an actor but you
know just he's a noble man a noble human
being you know and I think Stephen
I don't I can't imagine anybody else uh
doing this I can't imagine anybody else
meeting us on this journey man he's so
focused watching him in the editing room
I just stopped by to watch him in the
editing room he's over here just making
examples right yeah right making sound
effects
yo can Optimus
yeah
you know he's like he's like you see him
working out the scenes in his mind and
the team just like following along and
and and executing and you know he yo
he's he's just got a vision man he's got
a vision he's locked in he's laser
focused and I also think like
like talking to me about
me about like give knows I could like
communicate and talk about the character
and uh he said well give me your notes
at two o'clock in the morning I say for
real and he meant that and so we would
talk about this and it was a it's a big
franchise big movie he's like not a lot
of time always to do to things and he
always make the time and allowed me to
like sit with the writers to talk about
uh different things and I just thought
that that was really dope he is a man of
his word noble like you said yeah and
for me I feel like he's very
intense but not like in a like
aggressive way very like subtle
intensity it's very extremely focused on
what he's doing so much so that he like
you could be saying something to him and
if he's locked in on a specific thing
and making sure something that needs to
happen a specific way he might not even
fully hear you like you think he hears
you and like you'll have to like Snap
him out of it like hey Steve you never
be like oh you were saying something and
I'm like and I'm like yeah yeah I was
but go ahead get active uh so yeah he's
very like subtly intense and very like
super serious about making sure the
vision is executed the way it needs to
be done 100 I'm like what better you
know point of view to come from than
that of a real fan that like grew up
with it you could tell he's so immersed
like he wants to live and breathe and be
in the environment and I'm in a vo Booth
with this man I wasn't even on set in
Peru with this man but I you know he
like crabs Down On My Level like God
brought me into the world like helped me
understand like I'm a Transformers fan
but nothing like this man is he really
like lives breeds eats this entire scene
yeah I think he got a tattoo a
Transformers on his belly
buttons
someone with a movie tattoo I do respect
that yeah the other way now Eliza for
you you've had a lot of voice acting
experience before but Transformers in
particular feels like a completely
different type of production so what is
something you had to do in the booth on
this movie that you've never experienced
even with all of your past voice acting
yeah genuinely I worked out for this
role to not be on camera
to just be a voice uh I hope you can
tell in my inflection that I got a
girthy neck you know like I'm just swole
as hell in that Booth
but I really did I wanted to step into
the character I feel like I'm still like
trying to embody her today like back
straight like chest out shoulder bench
pressing at 130 and I'm serious
but like the step you know into that
character versus you know I'm a has
brother Hasbro uh My Little Pony was the
other thing I did come on so different
than this uh but this was such a deeper
character that I got to tap into of like
she's the first it's the first time
we're seeing RC like in a live-action
movie and to be given the honor of being
that female Autobot to be the first
there's so much pressure but also to be
you know the leader and the discipline
and the glue of the group and like reel
in everybody together when we're getting
off topic and be like no y'all come on
stay focused it's such an honor to be
trusted with the voice with the
character Toby for you I am a big fan of
Mo and I love your work in Mo and I know
that and this are two completely
different types of projects but what is
something that you managed to accomplish
in Rise of the Beast that you can credit
to having done Mo and having your first
on that set with those people this is
going to be
terrible that Mo gets to hear this for
the rest of his life but Moe he's gonna
take credit for being my first
quote-unquote acting coach he he like
walked me through how to do auditions
for the movie he oh he made sure he got
me all the way together but I think it
was specifically for this moment so when
she asked me a question now forever for
the rest of my life I gotta say mo was
the one who really gave me the guidance
to go execute and do what it is that was
necessary for
that is the highest honor for me because
that show is something else I absolutely
love it Dominic you teed me up for this
so I'm following up on something you
told me very recently that I don't think
I was allowed to ask more about you told
me that you would come up with pages and
pages of notes for Elena to suggest is
there anything from those pages and
pages that you can now tease that we can
see in the finished film we had to talk
about I think in the trailer or
something like that I can't remember
what we talked about but she's like I
really don't feel like my character
do this obviously you press for time the
producers are like y'all we gotta go we
gotta go we like you know thank God
Stephen was really open to it was like
it was just us let's just lock in just
us and um and we worked we worked to see
now we actually it actually changed it
um that day we changed the blocking we
changed the whole sequence which it was
changed lines and uh ended up being
something different because I did yeah I
just think that it was like the Arc of
really wanting to show that she evolved
that her like her weakness actually
being with the autobots and and being
with Noah actually inspired her in a
different way I love horror the
terracons are bringing the horror to the
Transformers film franchise what kind of
horror are they bringing and how far is
this movie going to push it in that
respect the scourge is horrible yeah
he's horrible like he's bigger than
everybody he's scarier than everybody
he's when you see Scourge on screen
you're like nobody can anybody beat him
yeah you know the decepticons look like
world-class citizens
yeah
yo I'm serious it's crazy it's great and
then on top of that you know you get the
Predacons
teaming up with them and there is horror
and there is uh there's doubt that that
these guys can beat him is there
anything that you can tease and Rise of
the Beast that could suggest that the
future of the Transformers film
franchise is especially bright because
of the movie you made I feel like the
idea of like nothing is ever really new
Under the Sun like things work because
they've been working a certain way for
so long and that's why you get uh you
get different characters from different
backgrounds and then the perception
changes and the lens from what you see
the things change and so I think like
with this you have these kids from
Brooklyn we've never seen Brooklyn kids
meet Autobots like it's never happened
we do often as black and brown people we
don't get the opportunity to see
mind-blowing things like like aliens and
things like mind-blowing scenarios like
like this and so to have that but also
have it take place in Brooklyn and be so
uh so infused and in the culture of
Brooklyn because Stephen was so specific
about that that gives a whole new
Dynamic and I feel like a whole new
world opens up because of the
perspectives that we have now very
different so much
better than two broken kids yeah
come on
[Applause]